hi in this video I'm going to solve a
question from IT Jam biotechnology 2016
and this question is on pure sense
basically pure sense versus
phosphorescence so before knowing floors
this question we should talk a little
bit about fluorescence and
phosphorescence and the basic mechanism
of these two so say for instance we have
a pure form and we would excite the
fluorophore with a particular wavelength
of light say for instance we have our
floor 4 which is actually GFP say for
instance our floor 4 is GFP and we have
excited our fluorophore with the
excitation light of 488 which is in a
blue range that is why I made this
excitation light as blue and after that
what would happen it would get into its
excited singlet States and if you don't
know what is singlet State or what is
triplet state I would recommend you
would go to my biophysical section and
watch those videos and so it would get
into a higher energy state higher energy
singlet state and as you can see it is a
first singlet state of higher energy
than the second and up to in a state and
there are fine states which are actually
rotational and vibrational states so
what happened it would get top into the
excited state and it would gradually
come down and this phenomenon is called
into internal conversion and after that
it would relax now the relaxation could
be in two ways one is it would relax in
a radiative fashion and it is relaxing
in a non radiative fashion if it
radiates in a radiative fashion then we
could see that radiative of relaxation
as fluorescence so these would have
energy corresponding to a particular
wavelength and these wavelength is as in
green spectrum so we can see our green
fluorescence out of our GFP molecule
and we are exciting it with the blue
light of 488 nanometer we are getting
some how excitation around 509 so the
first and phosphorescence is what is
called phosphorescence is really
radiative relaxation from that triplet
state so from this triplet state the
radiative relaxation takes place so for
the phosphorescence same excitation was
done previously excitation was done for
the phosphorylation phosphorescence and
then apart from getting straight down to
its ground state it would perform a
thing which is called inter system
crossing it would get into another type
of electronic state called the triplet
state and from the tip like triplet
state it would relax if it relaxes in a
radiative fashion then it is called
phosphorescence and if it doesn't if it
doesn't read it in a radiative fashion
then we can say it's a phosphorescent
phosphorescence so this is the basic
difference of fluorescence and
phosphorescence another thing
fluorescence is very fast it's an
instantaneous spot process but
phosphorescence is just a glowing dark
mechanism so it's this relaxation is a
far more time consuming and it's slow so
the let's check out the question now so
it says which are of the following
statements are correct as it's in an MS
Q section that means multiple options
could be correct now we see so
fluorescence has much longer decay
period than the phosphorescence so this
particular thing is actually not correct
cause fluorescence is fairly first so
fluorescence could not have a longer
decay period than phosphorescence
phosphorescence has longer decay period
so this option is incorrect and
radiative transition from t12 is 0 is
actually phosphorescence yeah you can
see that radiative relaxation from
triplet state to its ground state it's
called the phosphorescence so this
option is correct let's judge the second
option
so these radiative transition
from s 1 to s 0 is fluorescence yeah you
can see from s 1 to s 0 the radiative
transition is called fluorescence so it
would be actually correct and the last
one is enhancing the lifetime of excited
state is quenching now quenching is a
totally different phenomena quenching is
somewhat like using the excitation
spectra of one floor for by another
floor for another floor is using that
excitation and that emission spectra of
a particular floor for as its excitation
spectra so this option is still
incorrect
so it's an incorrect option so for this
particular question the two correct
options are B and C I would recommend
you would check my video on fluorescence
versus phosphorescence and it would
clear your concept even more hope you
enjoyed the video please like and give
it a quick thumbs up thank you